i'm one of the few people in the
conference i suppose who is going to say
images and videos are special
or visual data
and that is the case because they are
rich in information and data science and
ml techniques have now helped companies
in different domains like smart retail
smart agriculture medical imaging help
unlock insights that these data types
contain
um
and and natural and enable better
customer experience which can give them
a competitive edge if done right
well that has naturally led to an
increase in the amount of visual data
that needs to be managed how frequently
it is accessed so then the question is
do we know how to do it right
and and the reason that's a question is
because um images and videos can be
large an image can be two gigabyte large
and then there are millions of um they
usually occur in large quantities so you
know you have millions of images and
video
the processing requirements of this data
type is different so you think about
resize rotate sampling videos the
computational intensity of these
operations can be quite
different than if you were doing some an
average on num on numerical data
and lastly the metadata forms a key
piece in being able to manage or access
and it describes not just the objects
but what's contained in the object where
the where did the information come from
so let's see if we have a handle on
taking on managing this data we'll take
uh imagine you're a data scientist who
has to retrain a model to classify
thousands of you who has to train a
model to classify thousands of new
classes on hundreds of thousands of new
images that were just dumped in some
cloud bucket so typically today in uh
particularly in a large
company
what this would mean
is first you have to find out which
table the metadata got dumped in then
you have to get permission to access the
table then you're going to write some
complex metadata query like you know
with a bunch of joins to actually get
the urls of the data for where it lives
once you have that it gets worse because
now you have to make sure that
your
you have access to the data buckets you
allocate a big enough vm so that you can
download all those images on your local
machine and are able to process them
then you go ahead uh download them with
the urls that you got access to and
maybe to prepare the data set you're
going to have to do some pre-processing
that code is just to make you realize
that it actually gets pretty complex
particularly as you go with like a lot
more data or if you start dealing with
videos
so after you've spent maybe hours
sometimes days you finally can actually
go ahead and train and classify your
models
this was the data management status quo
that we encountered when intel started
their
research center along with carnegie
mellon and stanford to design visual
cloud systems my co-founder and i were
really excited that oh you know we're
going to get to work on cutting edge
research and deep learning and computer
vision with all these academic
researchers except we were responsible
for managing this data it's not like we
could pull some off the shelf tool
so because there isn't a database that
understands images and videos and so we
spent most of our time doing that and as
we talked to more and more data
scientists and ml engineers who were
trying to work with this data we
realized how hard the data
infrastructure was and how long it took
so since we were going to solve this
problem for ourselves we figured we'll
solve it well and make it available to
different people because
um and and that kind of prompted us to
spin out aperture data to prove that
just because your data is unstructured
it should not be onerous to deal with it
now after hundreds of conversations
with companies using or intending to use
visual data
what we have realized is just how
complex the landscape is for dealing
with this data type it's not just that
you have to deal with image and video
files when you're trying to do data
science or machine learning you also
have to deal with other data types like
there is application metadata there are
annotations sometimes there are
embeddings sometimes there is
pre-processing libraries that need to go
along and
it's to deal with these products you
have to deal with these in different uh
to deal with these data types you have
to deal with them through different
products because there are different
products designed to handle each of
these data types now naturally that
means this lack of interoperability
means you have to do the translation
among the various components yourself
which not only causes performance delays
but it also makes data life cycle
management very painful
um it's it's uh
it's also if you imagine they have to
pull data when you need to prepare this
data for machine learning you need to
pull these data types from various
components and that means very long
engineering delays we have actually
spoken to data scientists who are
reluctant to refresh their data sets
often or change the metadata or update
the metadata schema for fear of losing
more and more time not understanding
their data and being productive finally
the fact that you build these point
solutions means a lack of reuse which
further delays how you achieve your
business objectives now let me just walk
you through a classic development
sequence to really paint a picture of
how a diy system evolves and becomes
extremely complex as you're just trying
to get from input data into something
meaningful like trained model or a data
you want to display or some
recommendations so naturally you start
out
with some images and metadata or videos
and metadata they need to go into
a cloud storage bucket you might put the
metadata into some database of your
choice
very often you require labels to start
training and so you might bring in
manual or automatic labelers they will
want access to the data and then they'll
provide you with these annotations in
some formats that you either dump in
other cloud storage buckets or and or
maybe you are ingest them into database
so you can do searches based on labels
after that is when the diy or
do-it-yourself scripts come into picture
that pull images and the other
information together to feed them into
the ml frameworks or are front-ends for
display very often you might need to
pre-process this data
because you know maybe your neural
network requires lower resolution
images
very frequently you might also want to
index embeddings that describe the
content which means then you have to
bring in libraries for indexing them and
doing similarity search so the spaghetti
on purpose is to prove a point how
natural development leads to this
extremely complex glued together system
which can be brittle and hard to reuse
not really an elegant way to solve a
problem and imagine what happens when
you are using when you start putting in
other use cases and more data and more
use
and
multiple users
so really what people have been wanting
is a single unified approach to deal
with all these data types if you could
have a holistic purpose build system
that that could address all these things
you could you know it would improve it
would mean enhanced productivity with
simplified data engineering much faster
ml iterations such a system would be
able to evolve as your use cases evolve
and it would also be able to scale with
data growth all without disrupting any
of the user uh
user pipelines
that's of course what we offer with
aperturedb a purpose-built visual data
management system uh for anal for visual
analytics so aperture db
natively supports images and videos
which also means that we support
pre-processing operations near this data
so you can you know ask us to resize
rotate as you are accessing these data
types given the range of machine
learning use cases that we were
targeting now the other thing was how do
you store or model the metadata so we
looked at a lot of different
applications ranging all the way from
simple cocoa data set which is what a
lot of ml researchers start out with for
training going all the way to uh going
all the way to complex um medical
imaging and autonomous driving
application applications what this
metadata looked like in most cases was
uh was a graph it was
more specifically a property graph with
entities and relationships and then key
value properties on all of them and
sometimes you could group them together
by classes so
so that's why
we store or we manage the application
metadata as knowledge graph within
aperture db
and given that we were always thinking
about machine learning applications we
manage bounding boxes or annotations as
part of this metadata to allow you to do
label based searches
now a third aspect of search because the
uniqueness of visual data is that
feature vectors or embeddings can help
you define the content in these things
so
that allows you to do similarity
searches based on the object similarity
so the third thing we support is
indexing n-dimensional feature vectors
and do similarity searches now all
through we didn't want our users to have
to access these different components
separately so aperturedb also has a
query engine or orchestrator that allows
that takes in queries from the user
redirects them to the right components
in the system combines the results and
returns a coherent response to the user
what it exposes to the user is a native
json based query api which can then be
used by the machine learning pipelines
or end users to
to
to add modify search visual data and
metadata to perform on-the-fly visual
pre-processing to change the annotations
and feature factors uh or to do more
machine learning kind of tasks like you
know maybe taking data snapshots
now our design choices have direct
impact on the performance so you know a
common query in these cases for example
to prepare a training data set is to
search using some metadata criteria
access the images and very often like
resize or rotate or do some augmentation
uh now
all of those things are supported by
aperturedb through its unified api and
in order to compare performance of the
diy system that we had heard people talk
about we created our own where metadata
was serviced by uh postgres the files
were served by apache file server and
then we pre-processed the images using
the popular opencv library
we evaluated our we have evaluated the
performance using
queries on yfcc 100 million image and
video data set
and
and aperture db was 35 times faster
compared to the diy depending on query
complexity and 15 times faster on
average
now because we can pre-process images
and videos where they live near the data
storage we get a welcome reduction in
network transfer very frequently because
the common use cases you store high
resolution but your neural networks
expect lower resolution data so what i'm
saying here is because of our design
choices aperture db makes sure that the
data part is really fast and doesn't
become a bottleneck
now it's important to manage the data
and metadata but it's also important to
seamlessly integrate in the
the data science tooling ecosystem so
that it becomes easier for data
scientists to adopt to enable that uh
aperture db can store and access data
from cloud storage or it can manage the
data itself uh we also provide client
libraries for c plus plus and python
application development and there is a
good bunch of tooling around so for
example we have very fast concurrent
loaders to ingest data very fast into
aperture db
um we also provide data set
loaders to feed the data into machine
learning frameworks like pytorch
we also provide rest api so that we can
easily integrate with labeling
frameworks or front-ends that people
might have and we have our own web ui to
enable easier access and then finally
one of the missing pieces that we have
noticed is that there is a lot of data
science research tooling but in order to
be able to move the same pipeline into
production you require some sre style
requirement you have to fulfill them
like you need authentication access
control monitoring logging and this is
all the stuff that we have built into
aperture db
and what we have learned is because
infrastructure like aperture db can
actually be it can take a long time to
build especially if you have to provide
all that with the right api so one of
our customers told us it would have
taken them more than six to nine months
to build this needed three to four more
infrastructure engineers and they were
able to you know using aperture db
create a much simpler ml pipeline
we've also tested it for large scale
because of the design choices and we
were able to scale it already to more
than a billion metadata entities and
more than 300 million images
now with aperturedb of course data
scientists can move faster we've been
targeting to help them you know build
their recommendations classification and
all those pipelines fast through faster
searches
but we also help a lot of other personas
for example now the infrastructure
people don't have to maintain four or
five systems they have to maintain one
other data engineers feel there's a
simpler life cycle management because
aperture db takes care of maintaining
consistency among all these other
components
data science managers can see a lot more
you know coordination among teams
because now everyone has access to a
common visual repository that they can
work off of
and then of course there are sre style
requirements for any production
deployment which we also address
so now let's see have we really helped
and changed the data management
experience for data scientists now as a
database naturally you expect it to uh
you know help you understand the data
types it manages so we make it very easy
to find what your metadata looks like so
that you can actually start building
queries
and then data is the other thing
which we help you manage so of course
you should have an easy way to navigate
what's contained in your data so you
know we we have easy visualization to be
able to see what's in the data what your
images look like maybe the bounding
boxes that you might have put on them
now you remember at the beginning i
showed you this pipeline where in
today's systems you had to do a lot of
complex different steps except with
aperture db training and classification
literally becomes a matter of writing a
simple filter query and just feeding the
data set into pytorch and you can start
training or classifying
another interesting use case we learned
from our customers is that it helps them
debug their data set fast if you can
just turn a boolean on or off you can
actually you know just simply show what
what do your bounding boxes look like
what your segmentation masks look like
which makes it really simple to uh
understand what's going on with your
data set
then maybe you wanted to search not just
with keywords or labels maybe you wanted
to search without keywords and that's
where embeddings come into picture
because that's yet another way of
searching visual data and so we also
have very easy similarity search um
to enable you to search with
you know find similar look
near neighbors
i wanted to conclude with this um slide
to show
i wanted to conclude
wait hold on
have i been going on a different slide
sorry um i wanted to conclude with this
slide to bring back that you know how if
you have a purpose-built system
you can actually
you can actually start focusing on your
machine learning and data science use
cases instead of spending time wrangling
data types
so yeah if
that
bar the qr code should give you some
links to access and you know go to our
demo trial and other links thank you so
much for listening and if you have other
questions please find me during the
networking time thank you